this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by patreon
how you doing Mike hi well how are you
I'm you're very busy just really busy
just uh my fight is April 15th which
means it is now a month and a half away
and that means you have to train or at
least fight twice a day which uh while
working a full-time job and trying to
make content and dealing with uh family
stuff is a lot it is I have become a
machine
um making it work however possible uh
it's mainly about running up and downs
flights of stairs genuinely yes
no it might everything that I'm like
everything I'm doing in terms of
training is pretty good right now but I
just need to fight more
uh because I have some like just
emotional responses like I spawned with
a girlfriend the other day and I cried
almost the whole time while fighting her
um she
she's a lot smaller than me a lot
smaller than me and I like felt bad
awful and I punched very hard and I know
that I do and that's what they keep
telling me is the thing that's my Edge
is that I punch very hard which I think
is because I have a background of
weightlifting
um and I just felt awful she was small
and I didn't even really have to try not
that she was not a good fighter I'm just
a lot bigger than her and I was like
this makes me feel like a absolute piece
of [__] and she would walk towards me
and I would start crying so the biggest
thing I have right now is having to
reframe boxing as a sport and not as
violence in my head physically things
are okay mentally I hate it and I just
have to get through that so that's my uh
Challenge and I was actually talking to
a therapist about it to be like hey this
is like a big hurdle that I'm having
trouble Crossing and he was like look at
it as a video game you get hit you lose
a point you hit them you gain a point
and do that in your head while fighting
and that will probably help and I was
like that is genius that almost
definitely will uh help me reframe the
entire Sport AS not being about hitting
women and instead being about
competitive combat so
that's what I'm dealing with right now
um otherwise went to dice last week did
see both Austin and Troy in uh Vegas
uh went out did you go to that one
restaurant that Troy likes in Vegas
which restaurant do you go to no because
they didn't have any bookings available
so we went to oh I wish I could tell you
super freak out I think it's called it's
an Italian restaurant that um I guess we
just picked Italian and didn't realize
that it's like a whole Vegas thing where
they also
um have like weird psychedelic shows
while you eat nice so that was the ride
and then I saw Austin I missed out the
awards itself
um I'm pretty sure Austin was very drunk
I'm pretty sure I don't want to air you
out here Austin while you're not present
I'm sure yeah yeah this is really cool
Austin he gets swept up in the moments
of awards ceremonies you know it's very
excited he loves to celebrate his peers
okay and maybe to your untrained boxer
brain you know you see that as like
drunk but actually it's it's much deeper
than that it's a really you're right
whatever pretentious [__] Mike just
said that's what it is but it is an
interesting experience to me
um you've been in the games industry a
long time time Mike and you know a lot
of people I'm not drinking because of
the fight and I'm used to using alcohol
to make myself feel comfortable and when
we talk about networking on the show
obviously going to something like dice
is huge like dice as well a lot of
people go to pitch games that they're
working on
um that's a very big thing and going to
dice and not drinking I was a bit
worried about how I would do socially
because you have to get over all the
social anxiety
um there's definitely drinks culture in
games as well
it's almost pressured um you know I had
a my first experience of I ordered a
Coke and the bartender said really and I
was like yeah and he was like I really
thought we'd be doing something more
exciting tonight and I was like
wow um so first time I've had people
like judge me for not drinking and I was
like is that because it's a game system
I don't know but uh it turns out was
fine
um a little bit weird to get over but
then I was okay and I ended up feeling
like not drinking at these events uh is
more of a superpower and that I was like
oh 100 I remember everything everyone's
saying to me I can have coherent
conversations with them and when they're
drunk you actually don't feel that
socially awkward because everybody just
talks so much yep um so I wanted to
share that Master it's true I I have
been the man who's got a Coke that's
definitely a JD and Coke promise for
about three or four years now yeah and
it is a superpower yeah 100 if you can
get past that kind of the discomfort
that you everyone else is drinking and
you're not it's it's great for me as
well it's just like I mean it's tough to
explain to like folks who who who aren't
in games like
the most important powerful people in
games are at an event like dice I don't
want to make a tip of myself basically
like and I you know and I've I you know
sorry let me reframe it I I want to make
less of a tit of myself because I'm
definitely going to [__] up I'm never
going to say something stupid yeah 100
yeah but like I'm definitely like I'm
very aware that I'm on and you and and
you as well like we're both people like
you say who know people who have faces
that are out there there's a weird thing
about like an event like dice uh for
anyone who's in building industry for a
while where I'll be in a conversation
with a group of people and maybe not
know some of them and then sorry about
the dog and the squeaky toy uh part way
through the conversation realized they
knew who I was the whole time I just
didn't know who they were so you do have
to be very on and it's just it's like we
said there's a very prevalent drinking
culture in the games industry like when
we talk about networking which really is
just an elaborate way of saying meeting
cool people that you'd like to work with
that's all it is um and you do have to
do it and I do think it's very important
and I will advocate for being extremely
socially awkward and people make
assumptions about me when they meet me
all the time because I don't make a
great first impression that's definitely
an issue that I have
um yeah people tend to think that I'm uh
really like standoffish because I am
usually when I first meet people I just
like I'm kind of like cool hi and I but
it's totally awkward it's not that I'm
judging them or anything like that I'm
just not great with meeting people
um
at least I've been told uh there's
nothing I can do about it but I had
previously used alcohol to make myself
feel a little bit more comfortable at
events like that now I can't I was like
how is this gonna go
and I I ended up just feeling a lot
better for it I know that I embarrassed
myself once I don't even imagine these
people remember this but
there was a guy at dice who was being
just a drunk [__]
um
people it probably is well to a pretty
extreme extent this guy was slipping uh
he got like 10 hotel room keys made for
his room and was slipping them into
women's hands
at dice so he's a man who works in games
and was just slipping his room key to
women at dice like quite shitty that's
not common at the dice awards that is
not a common thing that happens he was
like very shitty when you said guys
drunk I'm like I can think of like eight
people who I know but that doesn't sound
like someone I would know like that
sounds like something so he was like a
business side lesser Dev side to like a
sort of outside of of uh the scene but
it was like not something that is
commonly done but it is something that
happens horrible sort of recently yeah
very gross and he I think called me a
[__] because I wouldn't give him my
phone number and so I was talking to
someone from
um I think it was
maybe I shouldn't say the name of the
studio
um but I was talking to someone from a
studio and this guy walks up to me again
and at this point I was drunk and I was
just rude to him um so the guy that I
was talking to didn't have any contacts
with this dude being rude and I'm a
really big fan of the games that they
make
and he walks up and he's like who is he
and I introduced this guy and then he
was like oh cool and then I made some
joke about how he probably didn't know
any of the games that the studio had
made I was like have you heard of this
game what'd you think of it but I was
super rude to him and I remember that
being a thing that I only did because I
was drunk and I was mad at a man that
was very unprofessional that I shouldn't
have done that I don't know if anyone
will remember me doing that or even
think about it again but I was like
that's an alcohol thing where I really
wanted to be rude to this guy because I
felt like he was a piece of [__] but who
did it serve it didn't really offend him
it just I was just being rude uh there
was there was no that it was just trying
to take a stab at somebody just to
probably make myself feel better about
being uncomfortable around him or
whatever
I think that would not have happened
without alcohol I think probably
I think the probably the guy who you're
worried about embarrassing yourself in
front of probably picked up on what was
going on there he called me he made a
comment he was like oh you don't have to
do that because I was like oh yeah name
name 10 of their games so
I don't know that he did in any case I
don't need to air out
the possible the trauma I went through
with being mean to somebody uh but I I
feel like it's a thing that you don't
need to use it as advice and like
networking is a huge thing that we talk
about on the show and I do think it's
really important and you should go up
and talk to people and say Hi and then
leave like I think that's also a thing
that I that's how to do is if it's
someone I'm a fan of I go say hi and
then I just I'm like but I'm not going
to take up your time and then you just
walk away so that you don't offer to
make them uncomfortable
um and alcohol can make that worse so
I'm I'm here to Advocate before this of
like unboxing I can't drink or I'm not
drinking it's okay to not drink at the
games industry uh events um
yeah
I think if you're starting in the
industry if you're a young person coming
into the industry don't drink a game
events just on five different levels
just don't drink great way to make a
mistake
yeah but yeah or for Bad actors to
Target you true yeah what are you eating
nothing okay yeah it went a lot smoother
than I expected like I said I ended up
feeling like everyone else was silly and
I was not not nowhere that I judged
anybody
just that I was like
talking to drunk people is actually very
easy
it is you don't want to really have to
say much yeah
um and like you know I still saw the
people I love and and like I saw Vincent
Peller and every time that's usually
where I see him most and just gave him a
huge compliment and I have no idea if he
was drinking or not but like doing that
without alcohol probably made it seem
more genuine as well that I was like
you're so good at what you do dude it's
crazy
um it was just yeah big big fan and it's
nice to see everyone nice to see Austin
nice to see Troy uh obviously no mic
devastatingly no president
um I'm just uh actually no I can't I
just realized I'll tell you after we've
recorded yeah I know what you were doing
I just wasn't sure if you're not allowed
to talk about it yet no no no no no no
no no no no that is all okay
yeah your dog's eating your plant I
don't know if that's a problem if we're
worried about that he was eating a green
chew toy that looks like a plant oh okay
okay
yeah that's good yeah he's all right
that is a do you like my plants I feel
like I've done it do you like your
blondes I hung some things your
background's always impressive you've
got the you you're hitting that perfect
level with the tastefulness of the LEDs
like the strip lights that's all there
is you're at the right level like it's
like okay that's nice it's tasteful it's
doing the job yeah I feel like it really
does almost look like a gamer dungeon in
the amount of like merchandise that I
have this is a wall of games I have
worked on
um but
the plants I think there's a hell of a
complex the blog self like any any
nature any sense of like yeah it just it
just makes the place feel yeah human but
I love the flex of having the stuff you
want to put on behind you as well I was
like I need to put something on this
[__] door
all right let's have some credits
every piece of truth I mean my shelf is
at this point like 70 Trump merchandise
absolutely that's Kratos right there
yeah that's a lot of God of War um so I
I feel pretty good about the background
the dog is not eating any plants uh but
since I have you today Mike and we don't
have very long we really only have
another 15 minutes outside of saying hey
games industry events you can go you
don't need to drink
um have you seen any of the footage for
Suicide Squad the game
do you know I've seen everyone talking
about it and I opened the YouTube video
this morning to watch and then haven't
got to it yet but I've I've heard people
are less than happy with the it's a live
service game right but they're not
calling it that is that what it is
basically yeah um yeah that's what I I'm
not gonna ask you to like don't go in a
game you haven't seen or anything like
that but I did want to explore this
Rocksteady is known for making
the Arkham series which is a very uh
beloved single player Batman series
that's what they're known for doing
that's what people really like from them
yeah from a business perspective
why do you think a studio that's known
for that instead of going for a
standalone Wonder Woman or Superman game
you know they have DC license obviously
that's huge that's what everyone loves
them for and they performed quite well
why do you think they pivot a studio
like Rocksteady that hard
so I obviously don't know so this is all
just a supposition that's the disclaimer
I need to give he feels very friendly
about suicide squad he's got a very
strong opinion I feel very like I hate
when YouTubers which I guess in this
context I'm temporarily a YouTuber like
just applying like it's this is the
facts of the thing so definitely massive
pinch of salt just take the biggest
thought I think the biggest argument
like genuinely for when these kind of
things happen is I think I think the
audience doesn't realize the scale
difference between different parts of
the games industry so if you're making a
single player campaign like a triple a
kind of single player game there is a
limit to your potential for success with
that kind of game
um and to the extent the single player
AAA experiences generally only make
viable sense if for example you have a
high quality console you want to sell
via those games and that's why we see
those games going more and multiplaus
platforms rather than third-party
Publishers I think that that's the
reason I've said repeatedly that you
don't really have to worry about Sony
stopping making single player games
because they do that to sell you
Hardware not to sell games yeah and it
works because people want to play God of
War they want to play Horizon they want
to play whatever and to an extent
they're also they're they're also
capping a gap in the audience they know
that there will be enough multiplayer
games for PlayStation 6 right and they
can kind of allow that to happen like
most choices of platform holder makes
are strategic they are they are trying
to plug a gap or yeah trying to make
brilliant beautiful art essentially that
sells their platform yeah totally valid
so whether when you're talking about
like a third party so Warner Brothers
they are they are looking understandably
at the massive massive amount more
profit made in the multiplayer space or
in these kind of live service games and
making a bet the reality is they are
walking you know when you're looking at
AAA they are making an enormous cash bet
every game they make they're spending
you know tens of tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions of dollars on a
game the
there is a ceiling to single player
games that makes that a relatively low
return you know bet whereas if they can
go and make take that same team and make
a bet on something that theoretically
could be Destiny could be fortnite
that's the that's that's a an easier
pitch you would think there's like a
common sense thing and this is
definitely something like early in my
career I didn't get where you go well
why why don't water play Studios just
make lots of small bets on interesting
things and the reality is it's not worth
it for them they they're spending a
bunch of money to make a game anyway
they should make the game that has the
highest potential return business point
of view whatever as an audience member
we feel about that that does make sense
on a business level I think I think I've
probably spoken about this on the show
before but um you know I'd interviewed a
bunch of people about this and
I used to watch all of the uh or listen
to all of the um like shareholder phone
calls and I think I want to get back
into doing that because it's such an
interesting way to learn about it
I say to everybody who wants to get into
games media do that because most
YouTubers are not doing that most people
aren't doing that and they're not hard
to to get access to
um and it was Activision specifically
that had this thing about comparing
video games to other forms of
entertainment medium and hours of
monetization if you buy a video game
he's chewing part of my Far Cry toy
banjo has a lot of energy today
apparently it's fine you can have that
one
um it was like if you compare video
games to movies movies are 15 for one
hour or an hour and a half
uh a video game can be sixty dollars for
200 hours so that is a poor rate of
monetization per hour and that's the the
appeal of a live service game is that
you are able to monetize more hours of
gameplay plus it's easier to sell one
game and repeatedly monetize it than it
is to sell five games in a year because
some people won't buy five games in a
year so the strategy makes a lot of
sense um but what I wanted to ask you
about specifically is when you're doing
deals obviously I know you can't talk
about a lot of these but with like an
outside company how often do they
approach you and say hey we want a
Biffle game or are you getting
approached and and having people come in
and ask for monetization strategies like
when it comes to
um loot boxes is that a thing that
something will be pitched to you from
someone on the business side like how
does the the monetization come into a
Bethel games game uh from the jump
so it's usually there's so it's always
one of the first questions like on a
broad level like how are you going to
monetize this game is and what's what's
the business model for your game how
many units do you think the game's gonna
sell what price are you going to sell it
for what's up like straight away 100
yeah I would have thought you couldn't
figure that out until you've made a bit
of that oh you can't you can't because I
want to know it anyway no but it's it's
all estimation but yeah no absolutely
because ultimately it is they're
choosing especially if they're funding
it and obviously we've talked on the
show before there's lots of different
shapes of deals but if they're putting
money or even just time into something
they want to know that that time's
worthwhile so yeah no absolutely from
the from the jump they want to know how
much how much money do you realistically
think this is going to make is totally
one of the reasonable questions that's
asked as it goes on
um you'll then based on the kind of game
it is yeah then you'll start to have
conversations with our games you know
we're a special case you don't come to
my company if you want to make a looter
shooter with uh
this
uh it's come up a couple of times we
definitely had conversations about like
you know um free-to-play kind of stuff
has come up in the past when we've been
talking to people but but no like
no we we make a certain kind of thing
and a certain scope of thing and a
certain and our audience as well as a
certain kind of audience so they're very
so most people who talk to us are have
done their homework and understand that
that's probably not going to happen as
well I think I'm on the record as being
against almost every four monetization
so absolutely they know you know they
they Google kind of where we've stood on
this stuff in the past but no it's um
but no it's it's ultimately it is a
business and especially at the at the
level of the kind of of a publisher or
someone funding a game for them it's
literally a business like they care they
want to make good product But ultimately
they're trying to make money so yeah
unless you're talking to someone who has
a wildly different Revenue stream that
games are supporting that's going to be
I think what's interesting is we have
found a lot of those paths so when we've
worked with platform holders
um it isn't so much about the bottom
line of how much a game is going to make
they're trying to you know sell a new
piece of Hardware all this trying
they're trying to kind of promote an
image of what they're cut what their
what their console does or or what kinds
of games are available on their console
um also honestly it comes up with
license games
you know with John Wick we had a lot of
conversations about obviously they
wanted to make money in that game didn't
make a lot of money but they also wanted
to kind of plug a gap in the schedule
remind people John Wick existed be
associated in the game Space with like
original creative ideas like they were
in the film space
where people might approach you because
they want a specific image
100 it wants to be seen as I don't want
to say artsy but that's the word that's
coming to me you call me pretentious
earlier I think that's the one which he
said was pretentious
I think I think yeah I think working
with us makes the same I think we
specifically are definitely known by
industry as a weirdly unpredictable
company that makes straight choices very
different stuff which is awesome
yeah and that's partly just because I
have a very short attention span but
it's also like like something that is
interesting and people know if they ask
us for a pitch we get asked to pitch for
things that frankly are way out of our
league because people want to see what
the [__] will come up with and a lot of
the time we're laughed out oh one day I
will tell the story of like there's a
specific Mega IP that we pitched for
once where we made a pitch for it we
submitted it by the proper channels
there was a scheduled like massive you
know meeting we were going to go into to
pitch this thing and I never got to go
to that meeting because I sent in all of
our pitch documentation and received LOL
from the uh IPO now and that was the
last conversation we ever had oh my God
but that's it we're taking big swings
and and those big swings pay off and we
end up with awesome stuff like you know
Tron and John Wick and all these things
because when that clicks when the people
on the other side of the desk are are
excited you can do really interesting
work and honestly it's good to prune out
the people early who would not want to
go on a weird Journey with us so yeah
it's um but yeah I think I think all of
this comes into play and I think I I
think I think uh the audience
consistently assumes that developers are
more cynical and that money people are
less cynical than they are strongly I
strongly agree I've I've been called uh
shell of the games industry before
because of the amount of times on
YouTube that I try to advocate for well
this wasn't a Dev decision and also the
[__] you don't like is probably
something that somebody on the dev team
also didn't like and things aren't that
simple like why didn't they think of
this they did uh I assure you they did
uh that's that's definitely a thing
um and even like the money people are
still just trying to fight the Beast
that is capitalism which is we must have
constant growth
and win no no that's the thing is I
don't think morality I mean there's
obviously terrible business practices
occasionally but like I don't think
morality comes into a decision around
genre and monetization It ultimately is
Guided by you know how much do we think
we're going to spend on this versus how
much could we make and the benefit of
the the purpose of a company being that
they have to grow which is a nightmare
and I'm glad I'm not in that position
and I just get to write I think I might
have said somebody asked me if I like
wanted to have a pathway to be senior
writer at Sony and I was like no
I don't want to take more meetings and I
feel a lot more responsible could I just
write please let me just write I would
like promoted I'm good
um so another thing that I think is
really interesting about the The Rock
studies situation specifically Arkham
Knight came out
six years ago it was a while wasn't it a
while ago and when we talk about a rock
steady game and I think this is an
interesting thing industry-wide is when
somebody talks about like a Santa Monica
Studio game or a rock steady gamery
whatever game
half of that Dev team is probably
completely different people
and it's a weird identity thing where
like I think a Bethel game makes sense
for as long as you are there not to say
that the team doesn't have a tremendous
impact on the games that you make but
like as a creative director
Corey is doing that at Santa Monica
Studio he's been there since God of War
2 which he directed yeah it's he's
franchise directed that's what Corey
does he's the person who decides what
happens to the franchise and he's been
there for a long time he's left he's
come back whatever
um we talk about like even a rock star
game I don't know what that means when
certain people leave how does a studio
even keep an identity like Rocksteady
when surely half of them aren't there
anymore
I don't think it's the same creative
director working on suicide squad like
how does the DNA of a developer even
really exist when the teams change so
much and I think that's getting more and
more relevant where like you know 90s
rare was like 10 people and they were
all the same people it's so different
now that I don't really know what an
identity even means for a studio unless
they have similar creative leadership
I well I'm I'm definitely of the opinion
ironically given my job in the name of
the company I genuinely don't think
creative leadership defines ultimately
that much about what the studio makes
like interesting to be clear I'm a
curator I bring it together
for me I think the analogy of like a
city is a better one like I can be the
mayor of the city I can make decisions I
can pull stuff together I can I can lead
But ultimately
New York's going to be the same once I'm
dead you know what I mean like like
culturally I think when you're dealing
with things it's easy with you know like
if everybody at your team leaves
yeah and you have a whole new team but
it's still beautiful games
they would but if half my team left
it would still be I think the team would
carry some of the would carry the DNA
forward if if half the population of
London left tomorrow it would still be
London that's true like I think I think
when you're dealing with such large
groups of people I think there is an
Institutional memory and an
Institutional culture that transcends
any one individual especially transcends
whichever you know dude is the outer
mouthpiece of that company
yeah because I'd be right that the
onboarding process is the same
regardless of who the HR person is right
so like if I get onboarded at Rocksteady
and they say here are our values here's
the little document we have here's the
slideshow about what we do and who we
are you could hire a different person to
do your onboarding but that document's
still going to stay the same and the
training's still going to say the same
it's not a yeah I don't have the thesis
that it's completely different it's just
something I wanted to ask you about it's
very interesting it's hypothesis right
it's a hypothesis like it's ultimately
which which now everyone knows because
it was in one division right the old the
idea of if you take a part of something
and so like yeah like I feel like game
companies are much more like that I
think you can I think you could end up
with a completely different ship but
because you did it in incremental slow
process it would still be the same ship
I think I think game companies are
simple I think we're we rush too quickly
towards assuming that the director is
like the the creative mind behind the
whole thing I think I think that varies
like
all right probably
I guess
this [__] is so chatty right now I have
to take him out to poop right before
recording this he's like probably like
half done that's what he poops the most
sorry when he box the most
um I feel like Corey is distinctly the
creative
director
fun
we have many people from different
divisions like uh RAF
uh from the art department and then
Bruno Just gameplay
um who uh both just uh were able to
accept awards for God War Ragnarok at
the dice Awards which is fantastic I
really like both of them and play soccer
with Bruno and he's just one of the
nicest people on the planet so it's
lovely to see uh wonderful colleagues
get uh awarded um
but I guess they are all very they've
all been there for a long time 10 plus
years and they're all very of their
specific departments they set a tone
um yeah I guess but the tone is then
executed by others like and I think I I
like it's I'm not I'm not diminishing
I'm definitely not diminishing myself
I'm really proud of the work I do I'm
I'm sure the same is true of those guys
but the the the for me there is a
difference between it's it's about
priority and importance like I I think
it's possible for me to have a massive
influence on the work I do but also for
you know if I wasn't there other people
would continue and do I guess you're
right if I flip the perspective there's
plenty of stuff that I have pitched or
brought
to my job that
nobody else had anything to do with
really awesome and now what the hell in
the great room the great relay race I've
got to go because I'm getting the tap
because Gary's got going to work cool so
I'm gonna pass you over to Austin bye
I'm literally just saying hi uh and now
goodbye all right hey Austin uh nice to
see you why are you in a car because I'm
on my way to a meeting so yeah no
dedicated audio from me sorry are you
driving
I might be driving be safe please
um I uh well thanks for watching
playlist listen everybody
look how viral this will go if I don't
know please don't do that please don't
do that don't even jinx it we don't want
that to happen uh okay I'm on a very
quiet Suburban Street it does look nice
wherever you are yeah we have no clouds
yeah I know it's weird it's like you can
see the snow outside on the mountains in
L.A right now it's crazy
um in any case I'm a video game writer
that's awesome he's a video game
composer and thanks for watching please
watch listen everybody bye
[Music]
see it